[Music]
my name is nick ragone i'm executive
vice president and chief marketing
officer at ascension we're the nation's
largest catholic and non-profit health
care system
and i've been in that role for seven
years so my name is john beckstead
i've been with edward jones for about 15
years now
my current role with the firm is i'm
responsible for all training and
coaching
for our financial advisors and our
administrators out in
all over north america so the your move
chess program really uh
was born about five and a half six years
ago and uh
really came from a simple query for my
my son frank who at the time was
probably in fourth or fifth grade and
sort of just curiously asked me if all
schools like his
had chess and i said i i don't know i
have no idea and so i just happened to
call the chess club and i think i got
tony rich on the line and
said you know not for nothing but all
the schools have a chess team and he
goes no
in fact many want them but you know
there's a cost associated with it
and he said in fact uh the new
superintendent and
ferguson fluorescent was inquiring about
getting after school chess and i said oh
that's interesting
all school should have some type of
access to chess because it's a
it's a wonderful learning skill and a
learning opportunity for kids
for life not just through middle school
or high school but forever
strategy across the board has a dear
place in my heart it really does
i've only been involved for two years i
had the wonderful privilege as soon as i
moved here
to be able to move into a vacant spot to
help out and just to watch the impact to
see the different impacts
50 60 000 children who get to play and
have access to it
and here to have those services and what
strategy across the board
does is it raises funds to make those
services available
for everyone at incredibly reasonable
prices and oftentimes at no cost
especially for children
you know we um at ascension we're the
the nation's
largest catholic health system and
non-profit and we've probably seen
as many coveted patients as any hospital
system in the country and
um it's it's been sobering to see how
selfless
and courageous our caregivers have been
throughout the duration so covet has
been something the entire world has had
to experience and edward jones has been
no exception
we've been thankful through technology
we've been able to continue to serve all
of our 7 million clients
in addition to that with all of our
associates all 49
000 have kept their jobs we've been very
fortunate that we've not lost
any no furloughs throughout this we made
that our ceo made that commitment early
on
to take care of our associates take care
of patients
i just personally couldn't be more proud
of the work that ascension has done
you see there's more need than ever for
help in our communities
and this is one of those ways of giving
that help so rex and genie i know that
this is your passion
and it's probably one of many passions
but i can't say for
me personally and for all of the people
that benefit
enough thank you st louis would not be
the epicenter of a chess word not for
their vision
and it is building a lasting impact in
our community for generations to come it
is making our city a better place
their enthusiasm has really
inspired many other people including
myself to get involved to make a
difference and so
i think st louis is blessed and
fortunate to have their leadership and i
think it's going to be
something that generations of kids are
going to benefit from
you